as long as human beings had been lending
things to other human beings there's
always been the question of how likely
is that person that I'm lending that
thing to going to give it back so
there's always been this question of
creditworthiness is this person a good
credit risk if I lend them money they
are how likely are they going to be to
pay pay me back now people have always
found ways to come up with a solution
here how many how much money do they
have what kind of an income do they have
but in 1956 two gentlemen said hey I
think we can apply the the ideas of
mathematics of the ideas of statistics
to actually become a little bit more
scientific about how creditworthy
someone is and so these two gentlemen
started what is known as the Fair Isaac
corporation Fair Isaac corporation and
when I first heard the name I assumed it
was started by a particularly fair Isaac
or at least someone who an Isaac who
thought that he was fair so much so that
he named it fair Isaac but it's after
it's actually named after the two
founders Bill Fair and Earl Isaac so
it's but it I was actually the first one
was fair comma Isaac and Corporation
then changed to Fair Isaac corporation
and now it's often known as FICO often
known as FICO and what they came up with
Bill Fair was an engineer Earl Isaac was
a mathematician is an algorithm for
computing how creditworthy someone is so
they came up with an algorithm and the
algorithm has changed since 1956 cuz
clearly technology has changed and our
understanding of statistics and even the
world itself that we're trying to
understand has changed but they started
focusing on the problem of given some
inputs can I give a score that can give
you a sense of someone's
creditworthiness so they would take
inputs they would take inputs like total
debt total debt and actually not just
total debt but available that total debt
to how much credit someone could get
access to things like payment history so
have they paid all their debts on time
payment history and other things like
length of credit history and and the
types of credit so length length and
types of credit and other things like
how many people are inquiring about this
person's credit and things like that and
then they came up with a score and today
the modern FICO score and the FICO
really is the I would say the dominant
type of credit score there are other
types of algorithms that people use but
FICO is still the predominant one it
will give you a score that is between
that is between 300 and 850 so 300 at
the low end 850 at the high end and the
general view is the general view and I
actually talked to some folks at some
banks too to get their sense of things
that anything above anything between 780
and 850 is excellent you have excellent
credit you are amongst the best credit
risk you are you are viewed to be very
likely to pay off whatever loan you are
about to get anything between 720 and
780 is considered still above average
it's still considered very good and
anything between 650 651 do that a
different color anything between 650 and
720 s considered kind of middle or
average or just okay and anything less
than 650 is not so good often refer to a
sub prime prime would be an excellent
credit risk or a good credit risk or an
OK credit risk subprime means okay this
is this person's a little bit riskier to
lend money to so this is not not so good
now the question is who actually
collects all of this information in
order to apply the FICO algorithm and
this is where credit bureaus come into
the picture so FICO is and it's a large
multi-billion dollar company now that it
does many many many things but it's most
famous for devising the FICO algorithm
but the way that the credit scores tend
to be calculated is by the credit
bureaus so the credit bureaus
the folks that will actually that will
actually collect the data collect the
data your total debt payment history and
other things apply the Falco algorithm
and then give you your actual credit
score and the three major credit bureaus
are TransUnion Trans Union
Experion Experion and Equifax so if you
are about to lend someone money you
could go to one of these credit bureaus
and you could do an inquiry into their
credit score and actually you yourself
as an individual can go and inquire
about your credit score with each of
these bureaus and there and they all
they offer different types of algorithms
but the FICO one is the most used one so
you could get a FICO score from each of
these credit unions and the score might
be a little bit different because they
all might have slightly different data
here but the way that it would generally
work is if you were to go to your bank
and ask for a mortgage or and go to a
credit card company and ask for a credit
card or get a car loan that entity so
let's say that this is the bank right
over here
that might be interested in lending you
money they are going to go they are
going to go to one of these credit
bureaus they're gonna go to one of these
credit bureaus and say hey give me this
person's credit score so that credit
bureau is gonna look at all the data
that it has on that person put it into
the the FICO algorithm if the bank wants
the FICO credit score and give a score
right over here and the one and if you
have an excellent credit than you might
get a low interest rate or your might
you might definitely get the loan if you
have a good credit score you might still
have you'll get the loan but it'll be a
slightly higher interest rate but if you
have really bad credit you're probably
not going to get the loan at all now the
last question you're probably asking is
well how do these how do these credit
bureaus get the information how do they
get how do they know how much total debt
I have and my payment history and the
lengths and types of credit that I have
and the number of enquiries that come in
well in exchange for lenders being
allowed to make these enquiries and they
usually and pay the credit bureaus to
get the information they also agreed to
share this information so later on or
let's say this Bank does give you the
loan they will tell the cred
bureaus they agree to tell the credit
bureaus that you they gave you that loan
and they will also tell them credit
bureau about your payment history if you
pay them all on time the credit bureaus
will know about that and they'll be able
to input into your FICO score but if you
don't pay it on time they will also know
about that and that will affect your
FICO score